raise your hand if you think you've
checked your phone more than a dozen
times already this morning how about if
you think you spend too much time
checking email or otherwise glued to a
piece of technology I certainly do
too often I find myself hunched over my
laptop and vast library trying to make a
dent in a day's deluge of emails I'm
frantically slamming away at the
keyboard looking up at the clock and
frustration as my free hour of time
slips away as soon as I think I'm making
some progress I hate refresh and then
I'm right back where I started
technology speeds up our lives but it
comes at a cost we spend so much time
reacting getting pulled in a million
different directions at once makes it
really hard to think deliberately to
live intentionally makes it hard to
manage stress foster creativity but I
have good news there's a solution it's
the oldest trick in the book
step outside and get in touch with
nature you just might like it it was a
brisk early winter morning in my
hometown of Boulder Colorado I was just
back for the Thanksgiving break for my
first eight weeks of business school and
man was I exhausted
I've been sprinting non-stop to keep up
with everything that this new high-speed
life had been throwing at me participate
in strategy class so it looks like I
belong in this place drive to a clean
tech conference and impress those
potential employers go out to bars so I
seen fun and make some friends squeeze
every potential ounce of value out of
this opportunity but put on a smile and
act like it's easy
I was stressed out sleep-deprived I
didn't feel like myself I got out of my
car I bolder's Chautauqua park trailhead
put my phone on the seat and took off
running up the mud and snow-covered
trail I didn't know where I was going or
what I would do when I got there I just
knew I needed some space I found that
space on a rock with a viewpoint
overlooking the Flatirons so i sat there
nourishing silence began to wash over me
the crisp clear mountain air filled my
lungs a fresh breeze made the spruce
trees sway peacefully in the wind and
put a little extra lift under that Hawks
wing soaring overhead I could feel my
mind slowing down about an hour later
scribbled some thoughts down in my
journal before returning to my car be
patient be grateful and get outside I
came back to Stanford that next week and
I could feel my feet on the ground again
look my friends in the eye and be fully
present for my conversations I began to
meditate a practice that I've continued
to this day
nature can change your life and it is
right outside your doorstep the benefits
of interaction with nature have been
proven to us in numerous academic
studies they include everything from
increased pain tolerance to better
memory even reduce symptoms of ADHD
studies from top universities around the
country and the world show the time in
nature significantly reduces stress and
increases creativity but this wisdoms
been around for long before the academic
studies
many world languages have words
specifically for the concepts that
getting outside is good for the mind
body and spirit in Norwegian that word
is free loose-leaf the japanese word
jinlun yoku translates directly into
english as forest bathing many of our
world's most creative and brilliant
people seem to share the same wisdom
Albert Einstein once told us look deep
into nature and then you'll understand
everything better perhaps it's no
coincidence that both the Buddha and
Isaac Newton came to their world
altering realizations while sitting
beneath the tree I wonder what our world
might look like if we all looked deep
into nature more often it shouldn't be
that hard right you can find nature
basically everywhere well the sad part
is based on the latest statistics you
probably won't as our culture spends
more and more time interacting with
technology we're spending less and less
time interacting with nature since the
mid 1980s the average time spent outside
by the American child has dropped in
half 25% fewer American adults
participate in outdoor recreation
meanwhile the time we spend in front of
screens is skyrocketed and the US were
now up to an average of seven and a half
hours a day New York Times bestselling
author Richard Louv has a name for this
crisis he calls it nature deficit
disorder and I think it's pretty serious
but the good news is the antidote is
abundant in fact you can find it
anywhere on this campus you just have to
go looking for it louvre calls it
vitamin n for nature
take it regularly turn your phone on
silent and go lay out on the grass for a
while take a walk around and really
observe the intricacies of the bushes
and the trees open yourself up let
nature come pouring it when I finished
my hike above Boulder last Thanksgiving
my vitamin End levels were at a pretty
good high but they slowly started coming
back down again over time by the time
last summer rolled around I was feeling
pretty down this time it was a deeper
more existential kind of low you see my
dream job summer internship turned out
to not have this elusive get me out of
bed in the morning quality that I've
been searching for I felt lost confused
alone in my search for a happy and
meaningful life so at the end of my
summer I decided to embark on a Vision
Quest a two-week introspective journey
in nature culminating with a four-day
wilderness Sola in the desert of
southern Utah that journey the mornings
I was woken up with the deserts sunlight
on my face the towering sand stone
monoliths that stood above me and seemed
to wait for me to ask just the right
question the deafening violence of the
thunderstorm the deafening silence of
the watercolor sunset
that journey may not fit fully into
words but what I can put into words is
the impact that it's had on me I now
know what it feels like to listen fully
to my own inner compass I've overcome
numerous mental and emotional barriers
that have stifled me my entire life I
found a deeper vision for my future for
how I hope to give my life to this world
that journey in the desert is the reason
that I'm standing here giving this talk
today so what's your next step in your
own personal journey in nature it
doesn't have to be a 4-day wilderness
solo but I do hope it pushes you just a
little bit beyond what you're used to
you might have to invest a little extra
time and effort upfront to get out there
well I assure you the return on your
investment will be worth it you'll come
back clear-headed more productive and
less stressed and what's more you will
fuel your soul for me nature is the
ultimate freedom the natural world
doesn't judge me it welcomes me for
exactly who I am nature brings me
clarity humility and infinite
possibility a starlit sky reminds me
that I am so small but that I'm a part
of something so big an incredible nature
makes me fully alive and present in
every moment a mountain top view brings
me out of my thoughts and envelops me in
the wonder of the miracle of life the RO
once said I took a walk in the woods
and I came out taller than the trees
I wonder what some time in nature might
mean for you